I'm Denzel war we're here at feeds the
need in Cleveland Ohio let's see what
talents these guys got har you got a
hidden talent what will that be I think
myself is a pretty good chef you know I
throwed out in the kitchen a little bit
I'm kind of a meat and potatoes guy so I
do a pretty good steak I do like a
reverse sear on it on my smoker I like
it my wife likes it so we're good I got
my quarterback Baker Mayfield I heard
you got an impression Baker the Freddie
kitchen our offensive coordinator and
what you see is what you get with Victor
he's raised in Alabama so he talks like
this I mean if you want to play football
you just gotta go out there and do it I
mean if you love the game you got to do
it yeah he thinks he's a lot more funny
than he really is slippery oh you got he
got that pressure for you guys today
will be coach Bob Wiley man one of my
favorite guys he's my coach my whole
life Oh Jack's a hut hut shot
all right so Hut it's a hut
why these are the draw